das ist mir egal gefälschte scheiße
jetzt sind es heute hätte kommen zu
einem neuen video jetzt hocken heute
werde die er in dieser runde mit peter
mit spenden methode mit mir unbedingt
was ihr das c
sascha heyer und demonstrative der
fragen geben da sah ich bin mal gespannt
auf eine frage aus wer würde er in einem
lokal gehen muss sich brauchen verkaufen
aber kohle zu zahlen raus lernen relativ
klarer fall müsste dann würde ich sagen
kann also unser haus eingetroffen
wir haben über peter ist zu deren
leistung nicht eigentlich aber du wirst
ja natürlich zeit ist ja sowieso darum
geht wer würde er eine woche lang aufs
duschen 40 ganz sicher ist welche
econique und nico ich langweilig sind
das vier tage eine woche frage trotzdem
einfach alles beantworten indem er
watschelt hochhebt und zwar richtig eine
frage in ihren der wert von euch hat am
meisten eine schönheitsoperation politik
vor da wirst überlegenheit 3 2 1 mit den
spenden die die bildung spaß das bist du
ich finde es witzig dass jordi sicher so
auf eine enthalten mich mal lieber und
selber noch mal ganz ehrlich wie kannst
du diesen spaß zusammen sein so ein
hässlicher menschen klar die songs aus
erfolgte wiederum zu einer körper wäre
dazu ein junge
okay wer von euch würde er seinen
youtube kanal schließen weil er mit
heldt nicht klarkommen würde dass er
sich nicht genannt das ist mir egal ich
scheiße orientierter sony bietet sms
werden nicht gewählt warum hast du mich
genommen weil du ein kleines stück ist
klar dass solche bestimmung zurück was
du bist sagen
von allen guten geistern zur situation
passt und wer von euch würde er seinen
eigenen urin trinken infrage gestellt
dass wir uns alle einig und es ist nicht
übertrieben gelogen dass gerade in den
videos anderem einen fonds geworfen
trotzdem egal wenn ich meine christen
müssten deswegen ist auch meine
kissingen anders
das sagte herbert werde er und seine
besten freundin den freund freundin aus
sprang mit begründung schreibt zwar okay
ist russell crowe nico nico und peter
frey der 100 nach mal war ausgegangen
war so an weil ich mich am wenigsten
kennen ist außer einer ganzen in der
runde und da kann es am wenigsten
personen das jetzt du sagst ich muss
sagen ich kenne ich am wenigsten und wir
haben jetzt sechs oder dies nicht aus
wie sind sie schon so trat vor der
einfahrt deutschland aber nicht heißt
also noch nicht förderwürdig intuitionen
geht wenn nicht in position
ganz ehrlich ich habe genug wir haben
sämtliche vorstellen eben nicht doch
niemand würde es machen
also es geht schon darauf ist moderat
wir haben es etliche freundschaften
zerstört und seele würde mich jetzt
darauf freuen werden
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
bevor peter sich selbst in die luft jagt
und ich sie umbringen dabei kanal
abonnieren die können wir einen neuen
folge von was das geht irgendwie schon
so weit ist